If you follow me in Twitter,
you no doubt will have seen that I
have some pretty spicy takes on infrastructure as
code.
And you know what? I feel like I
am allowed.
I've been doing infrastructure as code with pretty
much every tool there is since around 2015.
I even spent twelve months working
at Pulumi,
one of the many infrastructure code tools there
are.
And my specialty take is that while all
these tools
have gotten us so far,
they're not what we need to take the
next step.
And the problem is the TerraForm resource model.
It relies on individually managing resources
and polling to check for drift.
The Terraform resource model has
no understanding
of real time or event.
So what if that were to change?
We're gonna take a look at what the
future of IAC
could look like if we built a real
time event driven system to manage individual resources,
and not even just individual resources,
but build in the ability for actor based
resources where resources communicate with one another.
Now we can't dive into all of this
today because it just doesn't exist.
But I set a challenge for the team
at Guidepad.
Can you take us one step closer to
where we need to be?
Let's take a look.
So let's focus on the problem statement first.
Why is the Terraform resource model broken?
Well, maybe broken is a strong word, but
that set the scene.
You write enough HCL
to have Terraform create an s three bucket
with an ACL and access control list
that dictates whether it's public or private and
so forth.
You run Terraform plan and it tells you
that it wants to create a bucket and
set the ACL.
You do a Terraform apply
and the job is done.
Now, unfortunately,
that's not really enough.
There are still ways for people to modify
and tweak that resource,
notably,
the AWS portal.
And while I'm using AWS for the example,
this is not unique to them and is
a case for all cloud providers.
The challenge is someone can go into
the admin interface, the portal, whatever you wanna
call it, the console,
and start to make changes through the UI.
We sometimes call this click ops because you'd
make changes with a click.
The way that Terraform or any other infrastructure's
code tool will detect this change is to
then rerun a Terraform plan or apply to
detect that the desired state is different from
the current state.
This gives us a plan that may have
to recreate a bucket if it's been deleted
or fix the ACL.
And this is just a trivial case.
And even with this trivial case, there are
some huge problems.
What if the future of IAC can account
for all of these
external influences
on our resource.
Now how would that work?
Well, fortunately, with pretty much every cloud provider,
we have access to some sort of audit
log, which is a real time or near
real time depending on your cloud, set of
events
that tell us everything that happened within our
accounts.
So whatever IAC tool could detect a deleted
bucket or a change in ACL
and trigger the reconciliation
for us.
And that's what we're gonna try to demonstrate
today.
And not just that, I'm gonna show you
how to use Guidepad just to execute Terraform
on Guidepad because, well, why the hell not?
But Guidepad gives us the primitives to take
things up one step closer to where we
need to be. I hope you understand the
problem. I hope you're excited to see a
potential solution.
Let's have some fun. So let's do a
very quick recap about what Guidepad is and
how it works.
Guidepad
is a meta platform that helps you build
applications.
It's data driven,
meaning that you provide your data,
your values
using the Guidepad type system
in a declarative fashion,
and it makes magic happen.
Now what's actually happening under the hood is
that we could request for a service to
be running.
Guidepad
is composed of multiple environments which have control
planes,
classes.
We'll get into this in a second,
which will then
orchestrate and manage those services within those those
environments to have access to secrets,
load balancers,
ingress,
and all the bits that you need for
an application to be deployed to production.
If we run Guidepad entity list environments,
like so,
you will see that I have two environments
available on my Guidepad instance.
These are two environments I can use to
run Guidepad services.
Now you may have seen I deleted an
attribute where we were requesting the control plane
class.
And I just want to show this in
its full value so we can see what's
happening. But our AWS environment
is configured to specifically run Python code
as we can see by the control plane
class.
Now this control plane class could be Rust,
Go,
Kubernetes,
Ansible,
and so forth.
Guidepad already supports a bunch of different types
of environments off the bat that you can
use.
And, of course, based on today's video, one
of them is Terraform.
So what do these control plane classes look
like?
Let's go into the Guidepad source code
where we can open Guidepad,
environment,
and control planes.
If we pop open Terraform,
we will see the code.
Now all this does is give Guidepad enough
information to tell it how to execute Terraform
programs.
It knows it needs to do a Terraform
edit
followed by a Terraform apply.
Now because we're running this in an automated
fashion, of course, we need to auto approve
and there's not much point in running a
plan.
However, that doesn't mean you couldn't have a
bespoke control plane that executes the plan and
publishes it to a Slack channel,
where it then waits for another event before
executing the apply.
With Guidepad, anything is possible.
What's also very cool is that Guidepad handles
state management for you. It stores the outputted
state files as artifacts within the Guidepad system,
meaning you don't need to worry about where
to put it and so forth.
With this control plane, we could, in theory,
create a new service,
deploy it to Guidepad,
and all we'd have to do is provide
the HCL.
It would run Terraform on a loop based
on an interval that we configure,
and that would be job done.
But, of course, you can do that with
your CICD systems,
with a cron job interval,
and there wouldn't really be a lot of
value proposition other than a managed state file
and secrets being in a consolidated place. So,
yeah, there are some benefits. However,
we want to talk about the future of
infrastructure as code, And that means real time
and event driven.
So we're not gonna use the Terraform control
plane, although it exists.
We're going to try something different.
And as I said, I gave this challenge
to the Guidepad team.
And I wanna just highlight that when I
gave this to them, they came back to
me with a solution
and not months,
weeks,
but days.
Two days to be exact.
And we'll take a look at the code.
It's probably less
than 200 lines of Python.
Let's take a look. So let's take a
look at our service.
It is called s three provider, and it
is 105
lines long.
Now there's a lot of things that were
implemented here that were done just to keep
things simple and quick, like embedding Python code
into
a variable.
We could fetch us another way by using
a git repository that we pull in, loading
local files or remote files and so forth.
However,
for today,
we have a very simple Python program
This is the boto package to speak to
the AWS API.
The bucket name is just going to be
the name of the service. If we want
to manage more than one bucket, we deploy
more than one service.
We could take this a step further and
actually define a bucket type within Guidepad, and
then we're just creating a type that service
manages the resources.
But for today's demo, let's keep things simple.
This fetches our s three credentials from the
environment
and then does a list buckets.
If it doesn't find a bucket, it creates
a web or configured ACL.
And if it does find the bucket, it
just makes sure that the ACL is correct.
Now there's a few things I wanna point
out here because I'm sure you're staring at
this and yelling going, why are we doing
it this way?
Yes.
We are writing
handcrafted
Python code
to handle resource creation on a cloud provider.
But let me reiterate that the Terraform resource
model is broken.
It only understands CRUD,
create, read, update, and delete.
It understands that you can update some resources,
but there are times where it'll have to
do a delete and a recreate.
With the Python approach, we can build in
much more smarts.
At the start of this video, I talked
about renaming a bucket. And I'm sure a
few of you realized that, well, in most
cloud providers, you can't rename the buckets.
You have to actually create a new one
and copy over all the files and then
delete the old one.
And Terraform would delete the bucket. However, it
wouldn't copy over all your files.
With this approach, we could bake that in.
We could create a new bucket,
copy all the files, and delete the old
because we're right in the code. We get
to decide how this works.
For an undeploy,
all we're doing is deleting all the objects
and our bucket.
Again, for this, we could decide that we
want to keep it back up. Now, of
course, there are life cycle policies that we
could apply across AWS and other cloud providers.
But again, we're trying to keep things relatively
simple for today. The goal here is not
to show you a future complete solution,
but give you an idea of how you
could build up using Guidepad primitives, a future
facing infrastructure
as code tool.
So stay with me.
Now, we're using a state machine as part
of this service
to understand
what phases we go through.
Now we keep things simple in this demo
where we go from deployed state to deployed
state, just always running a Terraform apply.
But this could be elaborated on. And in
fact, I think I may spend a little
bit more time on a future video building
something a bit more feature complete.
But all we're doing is telling it to
run the deploy commands
for deploy and the undeploys for the not
deploy plan.
Simple.
We then configure the state plan with the
two different phases,
deployed and not deployed.
And job done.
So
let's deploy this
and then see what happens.
So the first thing we're going to do
is run AWS
s three API
get
ACL for our existing bucket.
Well,
we have a bucket. Now what?
Well, let's run our Guidepad service
like so.
We can then come down here
and using the AWS
SD API
on the command line, we're just going to
delete
our bucket,
like so.
And what's going to happen is our service
is going to start, realize the bucket doesn't
exist and create it.
We'll then delete it again.
This time where it's going to detect the
CloudTrail event
and then rerun
the create command.
And as we can see, the bucket has
been recreated.
Now, we can continue to delete this as
many times as we want and it will
continue to come back
because we have a long running process which
is pulling the AWS API as well as
subscribing to the CloudTrail log to monitor for
events.
So how do we make this work with
Guidepad?
Let's take a look at some code.
Inside of our plugin, we have requirements
dot py.
In this, we define a new class which
extend requirement called CloudTrail requirement.
All this requirement is doing is allowing us
to set a number of lookups and parameters
to filter the CloudTrail log
and then to trigger things within Guidepad. At
this case, we're using a state machine and
a state transition.
Our state transition has some CloudTrailer requirements that
if they become true, the transition will be
executed from deployed to deployed,
meaning reconciled.
Now we could have different handlers for each
type of event
and have an array of phases where we
handle
lots of specific scenarios,
but that would require me sitting here for
hours upon hours showing you all the amazing
stuff that we can do. And we want
to keep this brief.
So let's come over to Guidepad and we're
going to take a look at our state
transition.
Specifically,
want to see the requirements.
Now what we can see here is that
we have a logical or
and a list of requirements
with the first one being a type of
AWS CloudTrail
where is monitoring for an event name put
bucket public
access block.
We then have another AWS CloudTrail
where the event name is delete bucket.
So if any of these events come through,
satisfy our requirements, our state transition will be
executed and voila, everything that we want to
be true for our bucket remains to be
true.
Now, of course,
because everything in Guidepad is is data written
to a system, we can query in this
way.
You may be thinking, isn't there something a
little bit nicer when I don't have to
learn a ton of commands? And yes, there
is a UI.
From here, we can see my Guidepad dashboard.
We have lots of services,
lots of deployments, lots of events,
a pretty solid overview of everything happening at
the moment.
We can click on state machines
where we can take a look at our
s three provider
and we can see that it's a relatively
trivial state machine that just goes from deployed
to deployed.
But you can imagine as you build out
more complicated scenarios with lots of stages and
phases and transitions, that this diagram is a
very good visual representation
of what your provider is doing.
We could also dig into the state plan
where we can take a look at our
SV provider
and we can see
the code that we've seen earlier inside of
our plugin and the Python file.
And you can browse anything you want using
the UI.
I jump it over to types.
You can see the types available within my
plugin itself and the global Guidepad system.
Like so.
So that's a rough idea
of what we can do to improve infrastructure
as code using a system like Guidepad.
It provides a whole bunch of primitives
that allow you to build anything you can
dream up.
In this case, we took advantage of Guidepad
environment and control planes.
We used an AWS environment,
which means our service had the ability to
query the AWS API
because the environment provided secret credentials that could
be consumed at runtime.
We used a very specific control plane that
allowed us to execute Python.
And just as reminder,
that control plane could be written by you
in less than a hundred lines of code
to run Go,
Rust, Perl,
PHP, OCaml, whatever you want.
Then use the state machine and state transition
primitives from Guidepad,
which take requirements.
These requirements allow you to hook into any
system. That could be CloudTrail,
it could be Webhooks,
it could be Syslog,
it could be container logs.
You can filter and transform those events and
handle them to emit more events.
And when those requirements are satisfied,
you can execute a service or
a state transition.
That state transition is part of a state
machine that can have one, two, or more
phases
depending on the complexity of the reconciliation that
you want, allowing you to build in real
time or near time
event loops for handling events within your infrastructure.
CloudTrail and an s three bucket was just
the easiest implementation to show you for today's
video.
There's no reason those requirements couldn't hook into
the Kubernetes audit log,
allowing you to get information out of your
Kubernetes cluster
to detect potential bad actors.
You could also monitor
DNS records,
TLS certificate expiry times,
and anything else than your infrastructure through a
single control plane,
which allows you to use a command line
interface or a UI to build that understanding.
I've struggled to decide or describe
what Guidepad really is,
but I am confident that it is a
new platform for building sophisticated,
distributed event driven applications.
I hope you enjoyed this video. We'll see
you all next time.
And to the Guidepad team,
thank you for letting me play with this.
It's been a whole lot of fun.